can you believe it's the fourth year has
gone by oh excuse me sir why are you
booing oh oh you know this that I was
booing yes I think we all noticed that
you were booing well I'm sorry it's just
that there are other much better Comic
Cons than the one in San Diego is that
right there are other ones yes hello my
name is Francisco googley only and I am
the president of the very real country
of Bolivia guei I brought a map wait
sorry it doesn't look like a real map or
a real country anyway I hear if I invite
you to Politico is Comic Con this year
it's even bigger than Santiago's really
that sounds exciting
yes but look equates Capitol believer
guapa lists hosts our comic-con in the
same giant stadium where we host the
Bulova guilin peaks and also these
special beloved olympics and the only
the president of bolivia is allowed to
compete olympics I won every event last
year Oh congratulations
very impressive I still don't think I
can come to Bolivia quays comic-con Oh
since I did not pay attention to what
you just said I will now continue
planning your trip your first stop at
the Bolivia a comic-con is to pick up a
badge which is short for badge eine
which is short for a bag vagina which is
short for why did belittle a Comic Con
make all of their bags look like vaginas
it's what you put your posters into Wow
I don't know why we did that I don't
know why
next you will wait in an incredibly long
line for the bathroom the line is so
long because of Olympic why we pee
sitting down
poop standing up and also do all of our
banking and driver's license renewals in
the bathroom ok I'm sorry
a lot of this sounds like extraneous
information
I don't need there no extraneous no we
only have the one aeneas rhythm
[Music]
[Applause]
why but I haven't even told you about
all the talent we've confirmed for
Bulova comic-con this year is a very
impressive lineup I'm sure it is I'm
just I'm sorry I can't make we've got
short temper man long temper man lactose
tolerant girl the flush optometrist the
octopus eye doctor the incredible Jeff
the cast of Chicago zombie Tyrannosaurus
yes the creator of shark Vilanch various
cured meats George our our our Martin
he's a juggler a banana cream pie every
Michael Jordan in the world except for
the former NBA player or the current
movie star the cast of the middle how
about that
it's very impressive yes but I saved the
best for last
VIP ticket holders get an exclusive meet
and greet with the spatula that Deadpool
uses to make pancakes
we have spatula exclusive that's that's
fine and I guess I'll see you there
okay by the way just one last question
why are you wearing all those metals oh
these metals yes in belivet way you get
a medal for every bowel movement in fact
I think I'm about to earn a new medal
right now no no no no we will see you at
the political cover condo you will not
get out
[Applause]
you